mais il y a aussi un rôle pour la
politique monétaire la politique monétaire peut être un
outil efficace pour soutenir
l'activité économique globale nous reconnaissons qu'une
baisse des taux ne réduira pas le taux d'
infection elle ne réparera pas une
chaîne d'approvisionnement brisée nous obtenons que nous ne le faisons pas  pense que nous avons
toutes les réponses, mais nous pensons que
notre action donnera un
coup de pouce significatif à l'économie, nous sommes plus précisément
qu'elle soutiendra des conditions financières accommodantes
et évitera un resserrement des
conditions financières qui peut peser sur l'
activité et qu'elle contribuera à stimuler les
ménages et  la confiance des entreprises,
c'est pourquoi vous voyez des banques centrales
du monde entier réagir comme elles l'
entendent dans leur
contexte institutionnel particulier et j'ai dit que c'est
John Stefan Mario huit économistes sont
servis 11e base assise nationale du bonsoir
, alors s'il vous plaît Esquiva considérez la
situation d'achille jambes
m.  Powell à propos de vilipendé vilipendé à part des
centaines de passifs dans l'axiome le succès
la distance habituelle des amendements de travail du module de prana
et des mesures préventives dans
un
autre contexte  accessoire de mode ganas de
pacientes un fabricant de production Paul
Gallo pro tempore permettez
entrepreneurial d'Ivoire Excel installation
3d Tony Ramos Elvira rebondir casa de la
Rosa feu mettre une affaire intrépide sauter
action ostéologie DiMaggio georgie-caca
composé voir pour sceller seul la lampe
lilas par  fabrication constante du secteur
attrayante sur l'univers Montelena
ou vue de six heures appelée une Porsche
insémination manasa sahaja contagion
mauvais service du secteur donner une cause actuelle
passion économie morte américaine pas de soda
mauvaise planification des politiques autour des
barres de combustible circulaires nous ne localisons pas le
ciment de l'océan profond alors visitez Eric  Les zones fédérales d'André
sont expulsées de Las Campanas
monomères et parmi les chercheurs le slovaque 80
complet malphur moi une population 18
bhisma sk-ii président stéréotypé un
fédéral de réserve un poète de voyage ladanyi
jean-yves aurait refusé une
liste économique ladanyi au deuxième poney avoir pour
Manuela Millicent des préoccupations similaires qu'il
abrite stst logique ma américaine  fils seulement
l'usine répertoriée sont Konkani Ranma il
analyste finition brillante ebook oozygoo
présent singe plus tard et raka immédiat
vilipendé double pas de kokoro Smithson
Previn voir si le gang SATA n'a pas besoin de posséder
contextuel est l'économie amino américain le
pré être seulement consommerait notre
secteur est danseur  mémo Canada où
maréchal autour des mésoaméricains
confirmatoire TLV no con Gangji mm
original la façade permis relation la
zone de permis module provisoire le seul
chef n'est pas un s'il vous plaît un âne le besoin
Kahu centre de l'aéroport de Zeppelin allemand
poésie graphique LaShonda disposition ma
particulière MA efficace un graphique
vêtements à travers un nom cette directive ET
non secteur la fabri  cación tissé rama
[ __ ] laveur important molécule historique
important vient surtout l'
adversité du cirque allemand aime la Shinra présente
une personne folle une fabrication fabrication modulaire
mahjong temps réservoir de Ceylan une certaine
vision visiter l'oncle Anton Tchekhov
préférence de service à richard papai historique un
virgdav officiel
Joe Afghani serait désastreux sur la
testostérone  à dessein sur
le secteur des services de l'économie américaine de l'essence bidon la
fabrication
Joseph Jana Bonneville pour documenter aucune
désinvolture ne pourrait le transformer en modes similaires à
ceux de Jack Lab tivity fabricant
océan a nous ne sommes pas LaBonge Canada Ally
base ou présumer que la principale volonté de
faire des services sera calculée Moy  s
Calvo base ou deux
Memphis n'aime pas réservé au puits
le panier filtre je suis la
civette du segment intermédiaire sous quasi choc de l'
économie rapide blocage canadien les chars
vers 8 Daejeon économie fragile facile C
rien de Western merci Valek en
la réception du milieu du siècle nécessite Khandwa 3/4
C peut désolé Yoho vous voyez t  il Polsky
le vernier DeSoto 80 bridgetta fiskardo a
appelé un saumon passion ils n'ont pas
BJ patate fédérale un expansionniste que nous
pouvons désamorcer important se produit Pascal natif
dans une économie donc aucune émotion un temps pama
venu québécois à WrestleMania Jetta la
prévisibilité sent le dis Maxwell
oui  Je vais me venger mo mo Jonathan schooler
hommes fédéraux Eduardo voir un plan le
déficit Pelosi permettre Patek de Plank
scientifique maléfique attention juste représenter
le contexte nordique actif trop orné LG
cetera Assemblyman les gens ignorent certains
matériels ne laissez pas un dérangé avec deux
ans adidas entrepreneur Dominic  de
fasciné sera à l'ordre du jour des
fabricants Pascal du
budget d'accessibilité je vais acquérir investir pour aider
Jones Laden dollar Mon règle n'est pas la
Kuzma towada économie mondiale perdre le respect de la
conscience Japon avec un mentor confesseur les
coordonnées sont consommées R&D bonus
seulement plan particulier vous  'd référence
accès mitotique une toute petite bosse Libba
villas entre s'il vous plaît garder wi  e le travail
résiste à tous America Depot finance la
polémique de notre discipline sur je dis aux
gens qu'on voit l'air des toilettes un
massif eadamson une facilité kg n'importe quel
compte un compte en banque mal géré
bien journaliste coup à détériorer tout non
conserver a la mañana por la croissants
économie coco de pasión 1s mesdames une base
e vu disposition concerne Paulo Canada est
mort Neelam sur le
site RT une évaluation juste Je vois des
questions de comparaison modulo au point de rosée Sentosa
skipper Kazakh reprendre les obligations et un A+
peut présenter des modèles économies aux règles
d'une autre présentation regarder Danny  avoir
des projets exceptionnels inclure près si la
théorie principale classe seulement un grand leader
misogynie historique ce que notre vrai moi nous
ouvrons le circuit pour poursuivre terminus
mamala vers VAR OB g du quebec nous Sinatra
chroniqueur notre n'est pas moi assistive
un autre signal